Rick sorry sorry I can wait for this to wrap up
don't let me distract you
Welcome back everyone
big surprise they dropped a rick and morty season
five trailer there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
we have all these details about the episode so
we'll break it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes i will be doing videos for all the
episodes for season five and it does actually
seem like we might get ten episodes without any
breaks this year if you remember the season four
trailer when they released the first trailer and
the trailer for the second half of the season
both times they said five brand new episodes
in those trailers and in this trailer they just
say new episodes starting june 20th so there's a
solid chance that there's going to be no break
and we'll just get 10 weeks worth of episodes
gotta say i was not a fan of them breaking the
season in half but i will explain where they are
in their production schedule right now in terms of
season five season six season seven stuff because
they are really really far along in the riding
of new episodes but they start the trailer with
that scene of them in the creepy looking forest
running from someone and it turns into summer
just trying to one-up rick calling him out on his
tropes because that's usually something that rick
does is call out tropes when he himself falls into
the trope of horror movies saying it's too quiet
but you look at his reaction right after he says
it and he gets all pissed off before summer says
anything you can see that he did that on purpose
and he knew exactly what summer was going to do
like he's preemptively annoyed with her before
the words ever leave her mouth like oh here we
go again with this just as he gets trained with a
dart gun whoever's hunting them most of the other
big parodies that they have in these from the
different episodes are pretty easy to spot even
if you aren't really big on 80s or 90s pop culture
it's mostly 80s stuff that they're drawing on here
80s horror films and 80s cartoons because then it
turns into a big voltron parody everybody probably
spotted pretty easily there was a voltron netflix
series more recently though even if you're not a
child of the 80s or you didn't watch the classic
voltron cartoons it was pretty solid it ran for
a while but here they're actually doing it as a
vehicle voltron if you didn't watch that classic
voltron cartoon there was the original lion force
voltron the og team then eventually in later
seasons they did the vehicle force voltron rick
is the black pilot he's the head summer and beth
are the red and blue pilots they're the arms and
morty and jerry are the yellow and green pilots
they're the legs we don't get a full shot of it
but there is a big kaiju alien bug later in the
trailer so maybe it's connected to that episode
then morty looks like he got his ass handed to
him and is digging through the kitchen drawers all
pissed off about something he chucks this roll of
electrical tape rick storms up and doesn't even
bother to come up with a fake important reason
why he needs morty he just flat out tells him i
need you for some bull crap something he probably
doesn't want to deal with himself which is usually
the scenario that it's not clear where this scene
is happening maybe it's inside a larger version of
rick's lab or in someone's lab this dog man in a
spacesuit filled with green fluids seems like he's
trying to teleport into their living room and take
out rick like he's experimenting with a teleporter
that is not rick's teleporter i'm sure this is
gonna go well but then he winds up in the kitchen
where rick is trying to stop morty again who looks
like he's even more messed up starts fighting
rick then later in the scene starts fighting
morty yelling for the future so it's not really
clear where he's come from but i don't think
he's necessarily connected to the world that all
the dogs went to back during season one he seems
like a completely different type of creature then
there's a whole bunch of footage of the family on
this other planet fighting someone dressed up in
what looks like bdsm gear but because of the way
best eyes are stretched open and some of the other
references they make it looks like they're all
dressed up to be cenobites in hellraiser cosplay
whatever the situation they've got themselves into
rick has a marlin stuck through his chest and
through a giant ring on a chain around his neck
like the fish is literally sticking through his
chest in rick has transformed his arm into a
cannon he's got all kinds of weaponry and devices
built into his body so this is totally normal he
does stuff like this all the time but then in a
bunch of different footage from this same episode
you see rick fighting another alien cinebite
looking creature rick slapping the hell out of him
with the marlin and he literally says a hellraiser
reference confirming the cenobite theory
this is just another one of those scenes with them
walking into one of these audience chambers with
a bunch of those cenobite looking creatures
behind them if you haven't watched any of the
hellraiser movies i would recommend just at least
watching the first one it's classic 80s horror
clyde barker it's a great flick everyone probably
remembers this aquatic character rolling up to
their house on this aqua chariot that's mr nimbus
from the comic-con trailer they released last year
rick's nemesis that he hyped up is this huge
deal like he said i'm never supposed to go in the
ocean and just as he and morty crash mr nimbus
rises from the ocean and starts heckling him
richard you have desecrated the sacred treaty
betwixt land and sea now face the wrath of your
once and eternal foe mr nimbus sorry who the [
__ ] is that my nemesis what my nemesis okay okay
but what was his name again i am mr nimbus he's
gonna say that a lot pretty clearly he's meant to
be a parody of marvel's name or just the way his
character model looks you could also think of him
as an aquaman parody too but he looks a little
bit more like namor from the marvel universe
and it seems like either he's controlling the
water moving the chariot with him and the water
or a giant wave has brought him in with all
these creatures jerry makes a couple jokes
about him just gyrating around looking all weird
and then it seems like he and rick get into a big
fight mr nimbus snags rick right in the nuts just
this summer walks in in full wetsuit gear like
she's stolen in one of mr nimbus's weapons then
another big 80s cartoon reference for everybody
that watched saturday morning cartoons back in
the day this cyberpunk scene that rick talks about
seems like it's more of a transformers parody but
beast wars because all the transformers here are
based on giant animal transformers and whatever
the reason for them being here it seems like
jessica has gotten roped into this adventure with
morty and rick so it should be pretty interesting
the jessica episode from season 4 like season
4 episode 1 was actually pretty solid last year
also confirming the transformers theory in this
next scene rick's ship draws all of its weapons
out on a traditional looking gen 1 transformer
which seems like it's just a parody of one of
the sports cards but it also seems like it's kind
of a parody of the green roadblock constructicon
as if rick's ship has literally pulled up to a
roadblock in the middle of the street and you
see other cars in the background behind them so
maybe this is just a planet like cybertron with a
bunch of transformers living on it most of those
bumper stickers on rick's ship have always been
there since the beginning but it does look like
he added a campaign bumper sticker from the last
election it just reads glorto it's not really
clear if these aquatic looking robots are also
from the beast wars episode but it looks like rick
has tried to disguise his ship as another animal
transformer like a beast wars transformer so maybe
they just get caught while this is happening and
it's not really clear what the situation is with
this alternate rig but it just seems like another
classic rake versus rick's scenario like rest in
rick's laxation regis winds up spending most of
the episode fighting another version of himself
this is just the completed version of that comic
con trailer scene with them crashing into the
ocean and running into mr nimbus rick's nemesis
with finished animation the whole joke here though
is that as they're running away from a separate
disaster they just barely get away through a
portal the ship starts crashing to earth and
they think that they're going to die like they're
not going to survive the crash so morty's last
wish like the last thing he wants to do before
he dies is call jessica and tell her he loves
her as you would expect though things go sideways
and they run into mr nimbus whatever's going on
in this episode there's the giant kaiju alien bug
maybe that's connected to all the vehicle voltron
stuff that's going on during the episode but in
this scene you just see rick and morty sit down
like they're getting ready to watch tv and rick
just barely cares about what's happening outside
and clicks the button to turn all the house's auto
defenses on he's done this many times before for
several different reasons sometimes to keep stuff
from getting into the house and sometimes to keep
stuff from getting out of the house but this time
he's trapped jerry on the outside he probably knew
that was going to happen and just seems like
he totally doesn't care even though dan harmon
did say that rick and jerry would have more of an
agreement more of a relationship like that during
season five they wouldn't be best buds or anything
like that but their relationship would be closer
to what you saw at the end of worldly durley
conspiracy where they kind of come to an agreement
like they both acknowledge that they don't like
each other but they have to live together so it's
sort of a stalemate between the two of them this
seems like summer and morty's stealing rick's ship
and maybe this other boy there is just someone
who summer likes or somebody that morty knows who
accidentally gets roped in for their adventure and
they're apparently towing an entire solar system
behind the car just dragging it across space this
is another scene from that comic con trailer last
year too it's the scene that takes place right
before they crash into the ocean with mr nimbus
it's the wreckage of some other disaster that
they're just barely escaped like they're coming
from a previous adventure at the beginning of the
episode just like rest and rick's laxation only
as morty is running back to the ship with rick you
see all these countless alternate reality versions
of them in these gemstones like the gemstones from
season four episode one only these are purple so
they're probably a little bit different so zoom
in enhance on all these gemstones there's a bunch
of alternate versions there's morty cradling a
baby rick there's a cool guy version of morty
there's lego versions of rick and morty then even
though the big reference here is the blade movie
reference with both of them being versions of
wesley snipes blade at the club at the beginning
of that first movie if you look over here on
the left in the background zooming in hands
there's a version of them based on justin
roiland's original doc and marty pilot episode
like that's a scene directly cut and pasted from
that episode if you've never seen that that's the
actual pilot for the rick and morty series the
episode that they did to convince adult swim to
actually buy the series so that they could start
making season one so it's like the true original
version of the show and it's much more of a direct
parody on back to the future with just some of the
names changed a little bit also in the background
here there's a paul bunyan lumberjack version of
rick standing amidst a forest of morty trees as if
he's going to kill them all by chopping them down
then this scene of summer getting all pissed about
wanting to mess with rick's stuff seems like it's
probably part of the same episode where they steal
his spaceship but here you see another digital ai
rick like the ones from season 4 episode 1 trying
to stop them like there was a gang of ai rix that
were trying to get morty to go back and do the
right thing and i don't know if this scene of
them at the breakfast table with the logo looking
all tripped out is actually from an episode based
on the way they animated it it looks like there's
a tear in reality behind them to that alien planet
sometimes you can never tell if it's from an
actual episode or if it's just part of the intro
or for a logo then the tag scene that they end
on is rick just yanking the rug out from under
jerry metaphorically again when he makes it seem
like he's gonna help jerry do his bucket list then
immediately after describing a totally normal goal
like hey i want to see all these baseball games
at all the different major league ballparks
shuts them down hardcore like nope not doing
that they also try to remind you about hbo max
now so rick and morty seasons one through four
is streaming on hbo max but i believe you can also
watch most of the episodes on adult swim's website
and i think that they're still on hulu too for
at least a while so what will happen is obviously
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes there'll
be more promos and trailers before that happens
because obviously we're not going to get episodes
until june 20th so just leave all your requests in
the comments below if you have big questions about
what's happening with rick and morty right now
what's going on with more seasons beyond season
five is they actually just opened their writers
room for season seven so they're just started
working on season 7 episodes but the animation is
really what takes forever so that's why episodes
take so long to get out even if they are able to
release all 10 episodes without any breaks this
summer they'll still be down to the wire with
the last couple of episodes but it does sound like
they plan to release season six episodes next year
there was another big star wars trailer that
dropped this morning i'll try to do a video
for that for the bad batch series while you wait
for everything everyone click here for my brand
new marvel falcon and winter soldier episode
2 video and click here for all my other rick
and morty videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!